18 miles off the sussex coast operation
ocean witness finds what it's looking
for
we know their speed and we know their
pools so basically they are doing 1.5
knots which is they're probably fishing
it's a french trawler using a fishing
method that conservationists say is
unsustainable because it is so highly
efficient and greenpeace wants to stop
it
[Music]
greenpeace has been patrolling the
channel for much of the summer it says
industrial scale trawling has severely
depleted fish populations and is
declared a state of emergency
this is what's called a fly shooter one
of around 75 boats operating in the
channel it not only drags heavy
equipment along the sea bottom but it
also has a vast net that encircles whole
shoals of fish
fly shooting is legal the trawler is
within its rights but research shows one
vessel using the method catches as many
fish as up to 11 smaller boats and
greenpeace has joined coastal fishermen
in calling for a ban
local fishes along the south coast are
in complete crisis like we've heard time
and time again that they just simply
isn't enough fish to catch and they
largely blame that on fly shooters of
kind of industrial fishing vessel that
you see behind me they they sweep in
they can fish over a huge area extremely
quickly and then the local smaller
fishing boats they arrive and find that
there's just nothing left so they they
cannot compete with these kinds of
vessels
fisheries conservation scientists say
there are quotas on how many fish can be
caught in any one area even with fly
shooting but it still has a huge impact
on traditional communities
if you're a small scale boat fishing out
of a small harbour you're hoping to go
out every month and spread your catches
over the year whereas these boats might
come in and remove their entire catch
for the year possibly in the space of a
month and of course that then leaves a
hole in the amount of fish there that's
available to the small boats that remain
behind so
it's an issue of equity
the french trawler lifted its nets when
confronted by greenpeace its owner
didn't want to comment
the government said it was aware of the
concerns over fishing pressures in the
english channel and it wants to work
with the industry to tackle the issues
thomas more sky news of the sussex coast